analyst Professor Michael Clark Renner
breaking news you've never been
reporting on Sir Gavin Williamson and
the bullying allegations We Now
understand that he has resigned he's our
political editor Beth Rigby what's
happened Beth yes Tom just literally in
the past few moments a tweet has gone
out with Gavin Williamson's resignation
I haven't even read it myself yet but he
sent a letter to the Prime Minister
saying as you know there are ongoing
complaints processes connect concerning
text messages I sent to a colleague I
complying with this process and have
apologized to the recipient for those
messages since then there have been
other allegations made about my past
conduct I refute the characterization of
these claims but I recognize these are
becoming a distraction for the good work
this government is doing for the British
people I have therefore decided to step
back from government so I can comply
fully with the complaints process that's
underway and clear my name of any
wrongdoing he goes on to say it's with
real sadness I tend to my resignation
but I want to take this opportunity to
offer my full and total support from the
back benches I'm incredibly proud to
have worked with you in government over
the past few years and during the
campaign so Gavin Williamson there
breaking news
has resigned for government and the key
word in these kind of resignations is
always that distraction
it's the pure number of stories that
just keep coming out this this is it
diamond and you know over the weekend it
had emerged about the Wendy Morton
complaint and those text messages uh
were released to the Sunday Times uh
Jake Berry the then former party
chairman said that this bullying
allegation which Wendy Morton the former
Chief whip had made and complained to
the party that the Prime Minister had
been made aware of the bullying
allegations so that then dominated uh
the Sunday shows and headlines uh it
then emerged that there was another
instance of alleged bullying from a
senior former civil servant that person
tonight as I reported earlier has now
made a formal complaint to the
Parliamentary Watchdog as has the former
Chief Wendy Morton so that's two
complaints to the Parliamentary Watchdog
there's also a complaint in with the
party from Wendy Morton as I understand
it there were rumors and considerations
about even more complaints from MPS
about the conduct of Gavin Williamson
and clearly what has happened tonight is
that Rishi sunak maybe had a
conversation with him I don't know but
what's clearly happened is that that
message distraction has meant that Gavin
Williamson has resigned from government
dumb it was clear that this was an open
wound and the stories were going to just
keep coming and coming and Rishi sunak
has to go in for his third prime
minister's questions tomorrow
he's already faced extremely difficult
sessions over the reappointment of
swella bravaman as Home Secretary and
the presence of Gavin Williamson within
his government performing a ministerial
role in the cabinet offices clearly
become a problem that number 10 have
realized is not going to go away and
there could just be a drip drip drip of
allegations that are a distraction I
mean the the point of it all too though
diamond is it does call into question
Rishi sunax uh judgment you know he said
he wanted to run a professional uh
operation when he resigned from Boris
Johnson's cabinet he talked about
standards in public life and the way
government conducted itself matter in
and within weeks of being prime minister
I mean it's only been what two to three
weeks he's already had to accept or you
know the resignation of Sir Gavin
Williamson because he is being mired now
in controversy around allegations around
bullying allegations which he has denied
uh but this is one uh senior figure in
the government who helped get Rishi
sunak into office that's had to fall on
his sword today in order to protect
Rishi sunak from the political Maelstrom
around Gavin Williamson